بس مباشر يصور امراه مشرده في احد شوارع
مصر تعيش وسط القمامه يبدو انها مصابه
باسمه نفسيه حاده السيده كانت تعاني من
كسور وردود في كل جسدها خائفه لا تثق في
الاخرين وترفض المساعده وتفضل البقاء حيث
تكون مقطع صادم مشهد حزين التقطته سمر
نديم وهي مؤسسه دار
جمعيه خيريه تعمل على البحث عن المشردين
من كبار السن واداعهم الدار للرعايه
ومحاوله العثور على دوامهم المره يقولون
انها تمكث في الشارع للست سنوات ومؤخرا
ازدادت حالتها سوءا وباقيه اشهر بدون حركه
تقريبا والمفاجاه انها دكتوره مت مزيد
معنا دحجازي
[موسيقى]
طبيبه تعيش وسط القمامه فيديو واثار الغضب
والتعاطف في ان واحد بين رواد السوشيال
ميديا في مصر ما القصه
[موسيقى]
نسرين سيده في العقد الخامس من عمرها وجدت
نفسها بعد سنوات تعيش واقعا قاسيا مختلفا
تماما عن حياتها السابقه التي لا تتذكر
منها الكثير فصدمات حياتها تركتها في حاله
النفسيه تجعل من ماضيها لغزا لمن يريدون
مساعدتها
[موسيقى]
انطلقت سمر نديم مؤسسه دار زهره مصر
استغاثه من اشخاص فطرت قلوبهم بمشهد نسرين
وطلبوا منها مساعدتها حيث كانت تعيش في
الشارع بمنطقه تبه وتحديدا في ملف
للسيارات اعرضها مره اصطدام احدى السيارات
بها ماذا سبب لها في كسور واصبحت تنام على
بطنها طوال الوقت بسبب الالم ورغم سلوكها
العنيف ورفضها التحرك استطاعت سمر مع فريق
طبي متخصص نقل السيده الى الدار وتوفير
الرعايه اللازمه لها
[موسيقى]
و خلال محاولتي كشف لغز نسرين روت انها
كانت طبيبه وانها لم يسبق لها الزواج
ووالدها متوفيا ولكنها تم اختطافها في عام
2017 ثم انتهى بها الامر في الشارع ولا
تتفاعل مع اي محاوله كشف تفاصيل اكثر ولم
يتم العثور على اي اوراق يستدل منها على
هويتها لكنها مثقفه وتستطيع الحديث
بالانجليزيه والفرنسيه ولازال البحث عن
اهلها مستمرا لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي
القاهره
روح نايمه في الشارع نايمه على بطنها
دلوقتي شفتوا فاكرين اول مره جئنا عشان
ناخدها
من القاهره
دكتوره نسرين اهلا بكما دكتوره سمر يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك اولا نسمع منك القصه كامله
يقول بها الوضع في الشارع
وزي المسافرين عليهم خليها ساكته كده
حصل لها بصورها وفيديوهات على صفحات
التواصل الاجتماعي
على صفحتي ظهرت مصر نزلت لها من حوالي
شهرين او شهر ونصف حاولت ان انا اخذها
معرفتش اخذها ابدا ما رضتش تقوم معايا
حالتها ساقت اكثر طبعا قاعده الشارع مش
حلوه مش اا يعني مش حلوه لاي بني ادم مش
حلوه لاي حد ولا الانسان ولا الحيوان
للاسف هي كانت قاعده في مكان يعني ملف ملف
لعرضه لاي حاجه
حصل لها حادثه بقت نايمه على بطنها
فالموضوع اكتر وبقيت تعبانه اكثر
ولم يساعدها احد لماذا بعد كل هذه المده
علمتي عنها
هو كانت بقى لها احنا سالنا طبعا الناس
اللي كانوا حواليها في المكان السكان
وبتوع ال- الخضار والمحلات وكل الاماكن
سالناهم قالوا ان هي كانت جايه ولابسه شيك
جدا وكان بقى لها ست شهور في المكان ده
وكان وفضلت قاعده مكانها ما تحركتش وكانت
ناس كثير بتحاول معه تقومها بس كان كل حد
يجي يطلب منها كانت تشتمه وتضربه وتتفوا
عليه كانت بتعمل حاجات صعبه جدا جدا اي
بني ادم يعني يتحملها
ظروفها المرضيه وعارفه ان ليس على المريض
حرج ليس على المريض حرج وهي تعبانه طيب
وكان سلوكها عنيف مع من يحاول الساعاتها
كيف قدرته تساعدوها انتم وتنقلوها على دار
الرعايه يعني
امال خير صوتك يطلع ليه
فيديو لها وهي بين الحياه والموت وكانت
وضعها الصحي صعب جدا خلاص انا قررت اليوم
ده انا مش هسيبها ابدا وكان عندي اسرار
جوايا غريب لما شفتها بالحاله دي جاء لي
الفيديو ده الساعه 10 على صفحات توصل
الاجتماعي اتصلت بالدكتور الامراض النفسيه
قلت له ابعث لي فريق طبي بعد اذنك همم حتى
لو باي باي نوع من انواع حتى لو بفلوس انا
عايزه عايزه فريق طبي بيجيء لي محترم ينقذ
الست الطيبه دي من عذاب الشارع لان ما حدش
هيشيلها طيب الدكتوره عشان اعمل محضر
اثبات حاله بالفعل
ورحت لها ثاني على ال- همم على المكان
اللي هي قاعده فيه واخذتها بقرار من القسم
ان انا اخذها في دور زهره مصر للكبار
بيلمهدئه وشلناها في العربيه وطلعنا بها
هنا على الدار بس احنا عايزين نعرف يعني
هي ما شاء الله
دكتوره طب وين اهلها وين العياده اللي
كانت تشتغل فيها وين مستشفى وين الناس
عنها من كلها السنين اللي قاعده فيهم بهذا
الوضع المزري للاسف للاسف للاسف انا ما
قدرتش اسوق اوصل لحد الان لحد من اهلها
ونفسي بعد الفيديو ده وبعد اا كل ده نقدر
نوصل لحد من اهلها هي كانت مين وايه
وضعاها كانت عايشه ازاي ما شاء الله عليها
راقيه جدا جدا جدا في في في كلامها بتتكلم
انجليزي وفرنساوي همم ما شاء الله عليها
كمان طلباتها في الاكل مش طلبات حد يعني
كده وخلاص لا هي فاهمه في الاكل تطلب
الصبح مثلا بيض عيون بيض اوملات عايزه لبن
عصير ليمون اللي هو بتاع الفنادق عايزه
حاجات بتطلبها يعني مش شخص عادي مش بيتكلم
لا ده حد عاش ما شاء الله تبارك الله حاجه
حلوه قوي قوي يعني طيب
يعني من ستات ايام زمان يعني تحسيها هانم
في نفسها
انت عم تحكيني عم بشوف مباشره معاكي نسرين
طيب نسرين تعرضت وهي في الشارع والاستقدام
احد سيارت بيها ما ادى الى كسور في جسمها
وادى الى النوم على بطنها مثل ما قلتي كيف
يبدو وضعها الصح اليوم هي معكم
هي دلوقتي زي ما انتم شايفين معي كده بقيت
احسن كثير بدانا معاها اا فتره العلاج
الحمد لله ااا بتاخذ علاج يومي عملنا لها
تشيك اب كامل تحاليل همم طلع عندها وظائف
الكبد عاليه عندها همم طبعا انيميا طبعا
من قاعده الشارع همم عندها همم دهون
الثلاثيه فكل ده الحمد لله احنا بدانا فيه
نعالجه مع كمان الدكتور الامراض النفسيه
طيب دكتور على قد ما نقدر ان احنا نحاول
همم
اي كلمات جمل لافتام يعني خليتك تفكري
تتغيري مثلا اللي كنت عم تبحثي عنه لمصار
اخر
[موسيقى]
بصي هي ساعات كثير بتقعد تتكلم انجليزي
وهي قاعده ساعات كثير بتقول الفاظ غريبه
يعني مش حلوه وساعات كتير بتقول كلام حلو
جدا بتفهم في الابراج بتتكلم عن الابراج
اه اه يعني هي ما شاء الله عارفه حاجات
كثير يعني لما بتقعد مع الناس بتتكلم معهم
يعني في ناس بتجيء تشوفها هنا في الدار
بتتكلم معهم عن شخصياتهم والابراج وعن
تاريخ ميلادهم ما شاء الله يعني حاجه
كويسه
مع الجميع